[Music]
no let's just all go to hawaii [ __ ]
shoot over there i'll be sick i'm not
going to roll hawaii i have miles that
would also be a waste of a [ __ ]
entire day in hawaii yeah
that's maybe one of the worst things i
could ever think about doing i always
wanted to set up these tables and do it
on the beach
we get sunburned for sure this is where
i motion to just get three giant green
screens that we just put behind here
and we don't even put anything on them
it's just
and we're just we're just eating l l
yeah well then the fans could put stuff
on them
that's true let them do it
oh it's like that shia labeouf video
where you're just yelling in front of a
green skate to motivate you
so thanks to a legal loophole that
allows for things that aren't fish to
legally become fish these are now fish
according to california courts what the
[ __ ] did you just say dude these are now
fish these are equal to
fish in what context
oh well um this will set eagle too to
bumblebees are under threat mostly from
the agriculture industry's use of
pesticides and monoculture farming which
i do not know what is and don't ask me
what that is that's where you wear it
it's where you wear one monopole monaco
courtyard monoculture yeah it's killing
these man
no it's like having one crop oh okay so
like if it's corn you'll have [ __ ]
corn fields for miles and miles and
miles you can have yeah monoculture yeah
um so in 2019 the california fish and
game commission determined that four
species of bumblebee called
crotch franklin's western and suckley's
huh i like me some suckers yeah you
trying to suck leaves oh
you have a lot of sex dude yeah that's
well anthony lee's be getting sucklies
yeah this guy has a lot of sex and he
also receives a lot of liars like so
they might be candidates for endangered
and threatened species
protections um
and
there is a group that sued to keep bees
off of this list
so they argued that you know they don't
want to designate insects is endangered
but they are yeah well right but they
didn't but they're not included in the
statute that's already approved for
categories of wildlife to such legal
protections oh so then so then because
out of legality reasons they had to
throw it in a fish section yes exactly
so now so it's out of it's because of
stupid beauty because of bureaucracy
yeah they just wanted they wanted to
protect this bee so they're like hey you
know what they're fish
they're fish now
yeah
oh why can't they just have a b section
i don't know but i want to try [ __ ]
fish sushi with that's made out of bees
now
damn can you imagine
can i get a uh
bee spicy bee tuna
i'm sorry i ordered the fish sticks what
the [ __ ] is this it's bees
no it should be bees oh see what i'm
saying
like a real caterpillar roll has
caterpillars in it
you know what's funny about bees
mcbee
oh my god i thought he was gonna say how
does it come into
[Laughter]
you know what b is not a fish that's
what you would say um nick b
mcburney that shit's that's just serious
though you know like i saw this whole
ass documentary about how bees
are [ __ ] just dying away and
we need that [ __ ] to produce more fruits
and vegetables and if we if they all die
we're [ __ ] like we can't produce food
yeah i was like what's your problem what
about
birds they pollinate right what about
hummingbirds they don't roll deep enough
they don't not at the scale that we need
they stop yeah how is there so much
honey if there's a
loss of bees is there so much honey
isn't there i don't know there's it
seems like it hasn't gone down you're
not skeptical that guy
he's calling you out kind of it's like
they're not um they're not repopulating
at the same rate that we need them to
and then they're dying off more than
repopulating so it's like japan so like
um
what they did do is uh there's all these
like almond trees and [ __ ] right so
every year they bring out all the bees
and then they park it there so they can
pollinate it but then also the bees can
like get the pollen and then they can
make the honey so they have this like
you know relationship with the bee
farmers but then every [ __ ] year
they'll be like where the [ __ ] did my
bees go and they just die or they're
just swarms of them are gone it's
because of pesticides because of all
these reasons yeah yeah other insects
have you guys watch bee videos on
youtube it's [ __ ] fascinating yeah
like people who have bee hives that they
buy like online and then they set them
up and then they get the colony in there
and it's like a whole [ __ ] are those
people that uh they extract bees from
like gold
like they'll find them in the wall and
like legally you can't just like [ __ ]
demolish them you gotta call the bee
dude yeah to like safely or when bees
and wasps have wars
oh they do yeah
they make them fight each other wait are
wasps also endangered i don't know
nobody really cares about washington i
hope they are i [ __ ] hate them
i like bumblebees though they look like
like the bears of the bee world
yeah yeah wasps don't have the same
reputation [ __ ] wasps
what's the difference between a wasp and
a hornet because they both look ugly to
me
one's from charlotte yeah yeah it's a
basketball team
and purely
um but dude have you guys watched those
videos too where they they find like a
[ __ ] fire ant hill or some [ __ ] and
then to kill him they pour this molten
yeah the aluminum yeah
turns into a sculpture they dig it out
and like it likes hoes it all down and
it's like a [ __ ] sculpture it looks
sick let's just destroy this whole
[ __ ] town and massacre them so we can
have a
nice little it's almost like a a
rightful genocide yeah because who needs
fire ants what do they do nothing
nothing they don't even [ __ ] blow
fire yeah [ __ ] them
set them on fire or whatever send them
in an aluminum and then we keep the
regular i do think fire items need to be
eradicated and wash more mosquitoes
first mosquitoes [ __ ] mosquitoes dudes
oh man what would happen if mosquitoes
all just disappeared nothing but nothing
will tell you anthony [ __ ] nothing no
more famine and no one would be hungry
anymore no malaria everyone's just
[ __ ] great there's no random
complaints to play without something
like flies big pharma would have
something to say about that big farmer
wouldn't want it big farmer tried to get
him right back out there then yeah
because the virus they spread viruses
right mosquitoes are probably already
robots by big farmers but if we get rid
of all mosquitoes say goodbye to our
only chance to make dinosaurs again oh i
know
you know how crazy uh bees are they they
they basically have a gps built into
their [ __ ] system right so they'll
find some [ __ ] like miles and miles away
they'll find like a batch of flowers or
whatever they come back and then they
communicate through a dance and this is
where dancers are going to love this
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] committed
right to all the other bees that's never
been to that place and then they [ __ ]
go out
and they know exactly where to go
because of the dance did you see that
you had all the dancers attention yeah
they were like say more joe i i told you
dance is [ __ ] purposeful it's like if
you start like [ __ ] walking and be like
oh i know where he's from
it's like yeah oh [ __ ] it's the same
exact thing we're like
so
somebody starts all of us just go to
compton
so it goes is that where it's from i
don't know long beach i don't know
why are we all wearing blue do you know
what to put
oh man raiders oh man oh man we got a
crypt today
uh so so this judge says we generally
give words their usual and ordinary
meaning where however the legislature
has provided a technical definition of a
word we construe the term of art in
accordance with the technical meaning in
performing this function we are tasked
with liberally construing the act to
effectuate its remedial purpose wow this
is kangaroo court man yeah in other
words bees are fish
bees are fish they're legally so no one
really gets a [ __ ] about the bees
there's like no one's really trying to
save these bees they are trying to save
the bees that's why
in the brain
i don't know man that's just not not my
bee's knees [ __ ] that is that your bee's
knees it's not my bee's knees
i think we should save the bees that's
what i think i think so i want to get
more into the conservationist like
[ __ ] natural world mindset but i just
don't spend enough time
like i'm like i'm watching more like
insects kill each other and then like a
couple of b documentaries but then like
i'm not really trying to get into the
whole how do we save them do you guys
see a lot of like you guys see a lot of
dead bees on the floor sometimes yeah
all the time especially near power power
things but i've always wanted to have
i've always wanted to watch a television
show where you're like you know you're
seeing like a little penguin or
something and or like you see like
little cute animals getting preyed on by
other things yeah and i'm always
thinking about that camera guy and i'm
like dude what if like all of a sudden
in frame comes the [ __ ] bat and they
start hitting that [ __ ] thing
to save that little penguin or save that
little seal
they can't interfere you're not allowed
to but that's the [ __ ] thing like we
need a vigilante who's gonna [ __ ] go
out there there's national geographic
yeah that's i love those comments though
was when they're filming like a nature
thing and it's like a tigers eating
another thing and they're like why
didn't he help why don't you save it
well i mean you do that then tiger's
gonna die like tiger candy and also
they're like
they're like 100 [ __ ] meters away
because they're not really that close
like none of the safaris that you see
videos on instagram on though sometimes
they're just like eating them right
there and everybody's like
not in the boat videos the boat videos
are pretty cool the ones with like the
high production that like end up on
netflix and apple tv and all that like
they're [ __ ] really far away
or also they leave the cameras there and
then they like leave them there for like
months oh yeah because if they smell
humans around they're not gonna do
normal i think it's hilarious when like
when uh when you don't stop like a stork
from eating another stork like that
shit's funny because you know that's not
nature like come on whoa yeah i get i
get judged all the time when i when i
was recording these two high school kids
fight and they're like why don't you
stop them and i'm all like why you want
to [ __ ] with nature
this is what happens come on check out
joe's channel where he records high
school
and joe's like unfortunately we cannot
interfere
this is just the natural order here
in the land of world star
[Music]
you